what to you is the worst part of all of
this
the business model yeah the personal
red flags he keeps throwing up or
something else
the fact that i cannot with complete
confidence tell you their gap gross
margin
and i'm talking about that that is a
fundamental basic way to understand the
quality of revenue in a business that
helps you understand their burn rate are
they burning money to build a
recurring strong revenue base or are
they burning money to build a revenue
base they may have five percent gross
margins
and if they are doing that they are
throwing tons of good money to get
bad revenue and then it's ridiculous but
because they set up the s1 in such a way
that they don't actually break that out
my hands are off yeah you're not even a
thousand miles away one financial
analyst there's one
financial analysis firm which i think is
fascinating that it essentially
specializes in obfuscation like in
determining how much obfuscation or
concealment is contained
and this guy said look this is the
highest degree of obfuscation i have
ever seen
in a financial filing because like you
said they invented
i mean and other companies have done
this like uber and lifted it
aol did it yeah it is not uncommon for
companies to invent some kind of metric
that makes them look great
such as impressions yeah but
but he was like everything in here is
designed to cover up
their business model and that is a
screaming red flag